morgan why do you have a picture of dr
lahiri on your fridge
i have a picture of her never in my
house doc why wouldn't i
go hey morgan it's mindy from work yeah
morgan
from work mindy from work i'm sorry i
just my neighbor has a cat whose name is
also mindy
what's going on does this look okay from
the back because i feel like little
pockets of fat are shooting off from the
side of the vest do you have a different
vest
no i'm a different vest i'm not a hedge
funder okay relax
just don't be mad at dr l because he's
fun you're all so fun
am i tell me why oh my god yeah you're
so much fun he's always dieting you know
mm-hmm
and when you eat you're like i want
three pizzas
you know his farts are like sweet
yours are like um can i have another
drink please i'm very depressed pass
down to my kids one day morgan i can't
keep
talking to you totally understood hey dr
l if you're serious about getting in
shape i will train you
for this amount of money ten dollars
the price i like the trainer i'm dubious
about no no i know a lot about fitness
i was mr july in the men's prison
calendar uncle sam had sparklers and
nothing else
there you go that's your guy right there
okay that's compelling
let's do it i will let you be my trainer
on a trial basis for five dollars i will
pay you later
this is good i heard you feel kind of
confident but your hand's in the coffee
cake
oh god get it off of me guys i can taste
the cinnamon through my food take it out
dr l of those burgers try to break in
again they're toast i have a plan
i'm gonna get that doorknob piping hot
so if they touch it
burns their hand they kick the door open
boom paint can right in the head
put did you learn this from home alone i
didn't just watch home alone i also
watched some
grown-up films like grown-ups i watched
homeland and grumps
you know what if you're gonna stay here
for a very short amount of time we have
to have some ground rules yes we are
roomies with benefits
what absolutely not what about
friendship
oh yes yes yes go to bed just don't
touch anything i'm not even here you're
the best
you know what not a lot of guys would do
this no one is gonna cut you up into
little pieces tonight
what i'm gonna keep you safe go don't
think about it hey
you like eggs benedict i do so do i
goodnight goodbye real quick tutorial on
the remote
which button is pow okay i'll figure it
out
come here listen
you begged me to come here okay so don't
screw this up for me you little son of a
oh my god i love you so much she took
him to that wedding even though i'm her
best friend
[Music]
everyone i have a patient's emergency so
i'm just going to go to the hospital oh
i am going to go with you because it is
french dip day in the icu and those guys
can barely eat i
you can't come with me because the
patient is me
oh you finally decided to go on lithium
i think it's brave
i don't need that is it lap band
no it is not lap band surgery morgan
thank you for asking but what do i do is
there's something i should i call them
and be like
is it hey morgan i'm really searching
for the passion to continue my interest
in this conversation but i'm very sad so
i'm going to go eat my snack
so i'm going to go do that okay i try
okay come on engage your neck
all the neck come on doctor there you go
why is your crap so warm on my knees i
was
like sick a few days ago please stop
talking about it oh god you got this
doctor i'll only a thousand more
what else have i been doing this two
minutes hold on did you factor in the
time that took me to pick out workout
outfits
no no i didn't and well in that case
that's an hour all right we did it
not a boy champion no more you know now
this is what i was worried about it was
so easy to con you just then okay you
got to be tougher
i got i got it i will try to get out of
everything i got it okay
you're going down okay come on yeah
you're disgusting
yes you made me sick good one ah
hmm can you spat on my face i don't know
what happened you're fired you got cool
down you didn't even make snacks the
most important part of the workout
was the cool down ah sit and stretch
properly nobody raises babies better
than ken
no ken she can't have a male nanny dude
she'll attack him that's not true he'd
be into me and i'd be like get off oh
please hey guys how's it going anything
you want you can take anything you want
hi you look like a little bear cub let
me get these bad boys in here
yeah very new hey how many people can
spend the night here cause i told
everybody they could
none can no one zero okay yeah um have
you seen anything
yeah he's in my bedroom wait the living
room hmm
okay i don't want you to call it better
i sleep there so oh no no i'm gonna
stand
there's a space right next to dr c
you're not in good enough shape to stand
do we have a chemical attraction
yes of course do i occasionally think
about you in your yoga pants
constantly then let's just do this thing
and release me from this house
oh god
look at me look at me let's get you down
yeah
okay do you trust me no can you handle
pain
no okay sweetheart this is gonna hurt
like a
what on three one two i
my socks will stay on final sex rule you
can't fall in love with me
okay uh i think that alcohol is starting
to wear out so why don't you go to the
bedroom
and i'm gonna freshen up hair i've never
done it in the bedroom before
one time i oh yep
what am i doing
hey morgan you were right this is a bad
idea
oh my god hi i was gone for like 10
seconds
i felt like forever what it felt like
forever
uh you're using like a bedroom voice i
honestly can't hear you open those
blinds and let's let the stars watch
come here
please don't act so shocked and
disgusted it's a little offensive
take your stuff this is a big mistake
just remember that it was you that asked
me moments ago to have sex with you so
i'm gonna go and i want to thank you for
really really making this a great night
for everyone
your sex life is none of my business no
it is not but keeping tabs on it is my
hobby
i do think we're jumping into this too
quickly so let's take a step back
what is a bunk bed
morgan i'm sorry
i'm so glad you guys can make it i hope
it wasn't too much trouble oh relax
really the first people here
hmm almost 16 minutes late you're lucky
i don't know what practice you're from
oh we work at shulman and associates
established in 2003 a safe place for
women
may i continue of course it's weird i'm
talking at all
oh hey i got about 20 minutes left
there's a sign-up sheet over by dr
castellano's office
oh
thank you for doing all my checkups
simultaneously i wanted to do all my
medical appointments before i went back
to palo alto oh my god your ear's like a
wax museum
i saw like brad pitt and angelina jolie
statues in there i don't need a comedy
routine
if danny isn't that peter's wedding then
where is he oh god
hold on hold on just relax okay
don't jump to conclusions yeah you're
right you're right what's the worst
thing that could happen
dr c met another woman and fell in love
with her and he's with her now
oh god do you know there's no better
time to freeze your eggs than when
you're in your 20s mm-hmm and it's a
great way to make sure that your
reproductive health is
on fleek and that is cool
um your blood pressure is 1 billion over
1 million what's going on man you got to
eat better i know i'm just so stressed
do you think you'd get me something to
eat you want the breakfast sandwich the
bacon egg cheese ham
double bacon double egg chocolate cheese
hash browns too yeah expo is here dr
l i am nervous but excited what two
things are you
my two words betrayed and upset do you
want to know what danny tried to do last
night
danny tried to trick my body into giving
birth early
okay between me and you yeah i love dr c
he's always been the yoko of our
relationship
who am i the beatles who are you morgan
not a music fan listen the point is this
you are a confident beautiful ethnic
goddess okay
you don't let some man tell you what to
do with your body thank you
uh last time i checked this was america
and we respect women here yeah roe v
wade and stuff yeah roe v wade dwyane
wade all the wades
thank you morgan you're right you know
what i'm really excited for the expo
as long as this little guy doesn't try
to come out before the c-section oh let
me handle that one
hey oh sit sit
stay okay good boy get a treat
okay how many times have i told you the
only thing you had to kiss are my feet
you got it
what wait a minute why on earth would
you tell peter to leave the practice i
can't remember anything that i said it
was a pap smear i was just focusing on
not farting not that focused you still
farted
so i need to see him
so i'm sorry sweetheart he's waking up
i'm sorry you okay
he's an age he's gorgeous definitely not
a tucker's boy he's too small
no no why would you say that because i
was 16 pounds
so this is not my baby but but i still
love you little morgan did you get a
chance to set up those nanny interviews
that we talked about
hi morgan good morning has your wound
healed fine
hello morgan good morning how's your
wound healed
it's actually a personal question what a
waste of my time
morgan i had the best date he's cute
he made sports tolerable he paid for
three figures worth of chicken wings
see i told you it's not impossible to
date as a single mother
oh my god i'm a mom i didn't tell by the
kid did you tell them about me
no of course not okay
don't cry come on that's not don't
encourage him
you